secrets are like walls you can't really
know someone with walls between you it
should all be over it's too late tell
your father tell your father everything
[Music]
we got dryer we gave him the cure this
should all be over
but another cicada showed up absolute
5:17 time bomb we find out that that
mysterious guest that showed up the end
of 5:16 was none other than grace
Gibbons from the future I came back here
to work with you again to kill every
last metahuman
she is sort of taking the mantle of
cicada and that throws this massive
wrinkle in thawne's plan he has no idea
how to stop her there is only one thing
left to do you tell your father
everything
of course noir is a little apprehensive
about doing that she doesn't want to
betray the trust that iris and Barry and
the whole team have given her I'm sure
Lok Wells has really put all the pieces
together and he finally has discovered
who Nora is working with someone
instructed you to do it
hey everybody its charlie we got brand
new flash footage to break down a god
speed reminder because he's coming to
the show in a little while in a really
huge update about what's going on with
the flash movie in Ezra Miller status as
the flash of the DC movies because his
contract is up in November so we'll talk
about that after we talk about the flash
footage and the god speed stuff that's
coming up there's so many big changes
that are coming to the DC movies in the
DC TV shows this year be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I also
do giveaways every week - so here we go
flash footage you start off with the
flash clips and Barry's talking to Nora
about secrets and how they prevent you
from really knowing someone obvious a
big metaphor for all the secrets that
Nora's been keeping from Barry the
episode is called time bomb it refers to
the main meta of the episode that
they're trying to help but is also a
metaphor for what Nora has been doing
with reverse flash this metaphorical
bomb is gonna go off it also refers to
the grace cicada from the future like a
metaphorical bomb from the future
blowing up in their face when they were
trying to fix things by healing cicada
in present day the main story of the
episode is a metahuman who's keeping
their powers secret from their family
team flash tries to help that person but
obviously because it's all about secrets
coming out the B story is Nora telling
the truth to Barry and team flash this
is what I've been doing this whole time
you see reverse flashes countdown clock
in the future hit about 12 minutes
I believe this is minutes because I
think it was an hour one of the last
times that we saw it it's meant to be
like a very short amount of time but
because of the way time travel works
Nora keeps coming back just a little bit
forward in the timeline so it doesn't
seem like that much time passes in the
future like reverse flash probably just
gets a steady stream of information from
Nora because she keeps sending it even
though time moves for her in a regular
fashion when she's in present day so
this whole season his countdown clock
has been like close to an hour and it
just slowly counting down to zero I've
seen a lot of theories about what's
gonna happen when that countdown clock
hits zero right now I think it just has
something to do with them either killing
him or taking his powers away
permanently like forcing the Cure on him
because the whole idea in the future is
is the things spiral out of control
grace has gone on a tear metahumans are
outlawed is a worst-case nightmare
scenario which is why iris put that damn
pin
on Nora so Nora wouldn't learn that she
had powers and wouldn't put herself in a
situation that might cause grace cicada
of the future to kill her you see them
find reverse flashes times fear hidden
in the woods Nora is with them it's not
really clear based on the looks on their
faces whether or not grace
stole it in the future and that's how
she came back or whether Nora used it to
come back because she's been working
with reverse flash but it seems like
reverse flash has taught her pretty much
every skill you would need in order to
be able to alter the timeline so I think
that he probably also told her how to
enter the Speed Force to use it to
time-travel so it's more likely that the
time sphere is something that grace
stole in the future to come back you
also see Sherlock wells finished
decoding all Nora's time journal I read
through all the entries here there's
nothing particularly interesting in what
she's writing down sending messages to
reverse-flash all it is is her just
talking about lying to her parents so
it's literally her saying I've been
lying this whole time and Sherlock is
reading it like oh very clearly she's
been lying to us this whole time not the
smartest journal entries to make if you
were secretly sending messages to the
future I think she just assumed that
nobody would ever be able to decode her
secret language then you see Sherlock
wells sitting in reverse flashes special
wheelchair from season one the device
hidden in the site here I think this is
the device he used to siphon Speed Force
slowly powering himself back up like it
was one of the critical components he
used to juice himself up with Speed
Force
he used the wheelchair for a couple of
different reasons not just to charge
himself up one no one typically looks
twice at a disabled person like no one
would scrutinize him the same way it's
kind of awkward socially taboo to stare
at someone who's disabled like that so
you know people pass by him on the
street they wouldn't pay him that much
mind to the bigger reason is because he
built his speed force charging device
into it and just like a wireless
charging map for your phone in order for
it to work he had to stay in contact
with it for as long as possible every
day so that's why he would only leave
the wheelchair for brief periods when he
was in the Time Vault
I think there was an episode where we
saw him go back to his house where he
stood up for a little while when they
were getting ready to find out who he
was love the shot here of Norwich is
completely losing her [ __ ] because of
future grey cicadas so very clearly
right after episode 16 ends and grace
runs off with Orlan she goes straight
back to the future and starts screaming
and what do we do now and he's the one
that gives with the idea come clean to
your father that's the only way we're
gonna fix this Barry has a look on his
face like someone told him his mom died
all over again
then obviously the next episode episode
18 is supposed to be the god speed
episode just based on the script they
were calling it god speeds so I don't
know if that was a misdirect or if the
episode title is gonna be different but
I don't know why they would call an
episode god speed and then not do god
speed during that episode but all those
behind the scenes pictures of the
character in costume are coming from
episode 18 that's the one that danielle
panabaker directed we will probably see
the character in the trailer that they
drop after this week's episode so make
sure you watch the episode this week but
moving into the flash movie so if you
guys didn't see I posted an ESRI Miller
video a little while ago where he
basically explains the plot of the flash
movie as it's going to be but then there
was a big report a couple days ago about
how he
Azra Miller is working with Grant
Morrison of all people to write their
own version of the flash movie there's
supposed to be way more hardcore than
the original version they were gonna
shoot if that sounds weird because Ezra
Miller isn't known for writing movies
right now people think that it's a bid
to stay on as the flash because his
contract with Warner Brothers to play
Barry Allen in the DC movie universe is
up at the end of this year and they want
to start shooting the flash movie at the
end of this year so right now the
current belief is is that if Warner
Brothers sees his and Grant Morrison's
version of the movie and decide to pass
on that and go with the version that the
directors wrote they'll recast the role
and he will not be the flash anymore
it'll be some other actor and they'll
just continue on shooting the movie
later this year it'll be released
sometime during 2021 either way they're
gonna start working on the flash movie
by the end of this year so that's good
news I'm really excited about the idea
of a multiverse flash movie from Grant
Morrison he's one of the people that
originated the idea of the black flash
so if you're big fan of that character
you have him to thank for it but because
that preview video where Ezra Miller
explains the plot of his flash movie
sounds like what they're writing I'll
link that video at the end of this so
you can re-watch it all I really want
Warner Brothers to do in this situation
is just go with the stronger version of
the movie if they feel like the one that
Grant Morrison is working on winds up
being gangbusters and they love it and
they think that everyone else is gonna
love it then I'm totally fine
with Ezra Miller continuing on with the
character but if it's not that I am
totally fine with them recasting him I
feel like the character of the flash is
bigger than Ezra Miller so as long as
the movie is good at the end of the day
I don't care who plays the flash all I
want is just a really good solid flash
movie we're talking about sparking a
whole new universe which is it's not
just the DC x x DX
all of the disparate pieces of it
because Marvel is the universe right
it's just one world and all the same
characters in DC is a multiverse all
these different stories with different
realities different characters and
versions of characters and the
speedsters are the ones who move through
it all they're like the the connecting
bridge between all these different
collage parts even though Ezra Miller
sounds a little bit high in this video
he's not wrong he talks about the flash
being the key to the DC movie multiverse
and them pushing into that I really do
want them to get to the multiverse in
the DC movies even if they only deal
with it in the flash movies short-term
and then eventually long-term find a way
to do multiverse in a big Justice League
team up either way it sounds like the
flash is the first franchise that will
deal with the multiverse if you have any
big questions or big bonus videos that
you guys want me to do for the DC movies
or the DC TV shows just let me know in
the comments below
congratulations to the giveaway winner
for my last big DC video James Kegel
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here to rewatch my Avengers endgame
trailer video with all those Easter eggs
and click here to watch as Ram Miller
explained the plot of the flash movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]